I mean you have aass fans all over the
world and so what do what do they do how
do they react when they see you out and
about fans I I play a crazy person on
the aric Andre show so fans think I'm
like actually that crazy in real life
but I'm kind of boring a Suburban in
real life are you really yeah I'm in I
drink chimile tea and I'm in bed by like
10: oh I watch 90day fiance oh my God I
watch 90 day I knew I
love television um okay one of the last
uh few text exchanges we had was about
family and you write about your mom's
emails um Dan your mom's emails really
funny she sent one ever exactly what was
it it's like the tiniest thing yeah she
said dear hey Dan just practicing email
email okay bye that was it that was the
end of Correspondence that was an email
with her it was like it was like 15
years ago where that was you got it and
then she was just like dead air
Dan wrot back no more need to practice
mom you nailed it you mastered it that's
so cute but your mom like is more
prolific on my mom's emails are the like
existential ramblings of a mad man it is
like unibomber manifestos I don't know
what she's talking about Ted kazinski
she's the Ted kazinski of mother what
what do they like what is she I don't
you just have to read I can't do them
Justice they're like she she's got a
Roomba and she'll talk about the Roomba
and how it's like a feminist icon and
like she has her own metaverse in her
mind I don't understand them I'll read
them 55 times and I can't tell what
she's talking to give your mom my email
address that sounds like a fun read oh
be careful what you wish for be careful
what you wish for what do you guys think
it is that people have to overcome in
their mind to go for comedy goals and
dreams like what gives you the courage
to go out there and do what you do to do
pranks yourself I mean we have prank
recipes in the book you can start there
try to emulate the pranks that we wrote
for you to do at home how to yeah it's
like behind yeah it's behind the scenes
Expos and like our prank failures and
trials and tribulations of making the ER
Andre show and bad trip and other prank
Endeavors but it's also we have little
prank recipes in there so you can try a
little pranks is there anything you
won't do pranks don't want to be mean
you don't want to be mean I mean anybody
can be mean there has to be like uh
kindness you have to prank with love
even if you're torturing the person you
have to prank good love mhm I bet it's a
whole lot of fun dating you guys yeah
there's ups and downs yeah and what
about if there's people out there yeah
right what about are there people out
there who are watching this and like I'm
funny I know I can prank people can like
the difference between what you they're
sitting at home thinking about it you've
done it what advice would you have for
people who want to get out there and
make a name for themselves you just got
to do it takes years you have to like
fail for a decade before you start
really finding your sense abilities and
comedic perspective and POV yeah and I
would recommend this book I'd recommend
that book a true guide yeah there you go
well there f d ideas is out now and you
can catch Eric on tour um the Eric Andre
explosion perfect Title by the way
December 5th to the 16th and you can
also see him you're in
trolled with
ins thank you so much Eric and Dan we'll
be right
[Music]
back